and of course huge success and then you
had all those incredible celebrities and
you know star cameos and things because
I mean you were in scenes with Madonna
which and she didn't even know who I was
so she came in and she came in late to
the first read-through she kept her
sunglasses on and she sat down and she
talked like that I think he was sort of
a baby Sacramento accident I'm not sure
and then she started reading the script
and at one point she said listen Jack
what which one's Jack and Shan Shan when
hi hi Sean Hayes played Jack MacFarland
hi and most of her scenes were with
Meghan but every day she went to Deborah
and to I and she said finally I was like
this was when she was really into
Kabbalah and I said oh I'm Rahel my
Kabbalah name literally for the rest of
week she called me Rahul and that night
we always have a tradition where we hug
and kiss each other right before we go
on and I and he said okay he said have a
good show Deb and Madonna would turned
to him and was like her knee was not Deb
that's when he informed her what my name
was Debra and the next day after the
whole so duars over I got six dozen
roses and said dear Deborah thank you
for a great week Madonna so uh yeah so I
the same thing on the Friday we've been
working for three days she said I'm sad
I remember I said I'm done this is the
third time
my name is so easy to remember it's the
one at the very very beginning of every
single episode of the show you're on and
sorry so same thing I got a giant box of
roses with a card that I just found the
other day I thought I'd lost it which
said if my husband would let me I tattoo
your name on my arm
love Madonna so I always forget
wrist pictures of Madonna lately it's
got ruffle right
[Applause]
[Music]
you